doctor could you explain for the benefit
of the
viewers what is the exact correct time
to begin and end the
Ia particularly pertaining to the last
10 days of Ramadan as far as beginning
of EA for the last 10 years ran is
concerned there is a difference of
opinion between the scholars one group
of
Scholars people like
alai people like Ali or IM Al may Allah
be pleased with them all they say
that should begin after the F Salah on
the 21st night based on the Hadith which
is mentioned in s bukari volume number
three in the book of Hadith number 2034
as well as
2041 that be pleased with her she said
that the prophet used to DOA for the
last 10 days of Ramadan and I used to
push the tent for him and after F Salah
he used to come at the place of and
enter the tent So based on this had that
the prophet M wasallam after offering F
Salah used to come at the place of and
enter the tent these callar they say
that should start after F Salah this is
the view of shik Bin Also may Allah have
mercy on him when he was asked that when
should start he said they should start
after F Salah of the 21st day of Ramadan
if you want to fast in the last 10 days
based on the the same of with her but
the majority of the scholars the other
Scholars including all the fouras IM Abu
hanifah Imam Malik Imam Shafi Imam Ahmed
hbal and most of the scholar they say
that if you want to DOA in the last 10
days of Raman Thea should start before
the sunset of the
21st night because the day starts with
the sunset so because you have to do e
in the last 10 days have to do before
Sunset and they say because the main aim
objective of is to
seek and is in the night so if you have
to do in the last 10 nights it includes
the 21st night
also and since the prophet said as we
discussed yesterday
that on the odd nights of the last 10
nights which includes the 21st night so
if you start from F you are missing the
21st night therefore most of the
scholars agree that should start Before
Sunset of the 21st night and in reply to
the
of ofari volum number three in the book
of Hadith number 2034 and Hadith number
20141 that Prophet M Sall Ali wasallam
used to do in the last 10 days of
Ramadan and I used to pitch the tent for
him and he used to offer the F Salah and
after offering Salah is to come at the
place of so what did scholar say this
Hadith never says that Prophet
started after F Salah it says the
prophet came to the place of came to his
tent because he wanted seclusion from
the other people after F Salah what they
say even here it actually indicates that
if Prophet has to get the night of 21st
he started EA Before Sunset so the
Prophet entered the mosque Before Sunset
of the 21st night so the EA starts
Before Sunset but he prayed in the
mosque and he came to the place of that
is the tent because he wanted seclusion
from the other people after F Salah so
according to the correct view according
major
Scholars Thea starts before the sunset
of
21st night that is before breaking the
fast of the 20th day when you fast for
the 20th day of Ramadan before you break
the F Before Sunset you start your and
when may Allah have mercy on him when he
was asked when should EA start for the
last 10 days he gave the same reply
according the major group of Scholars it
should start Before Sunset of the 21st
night that is before breaking the fast
of the 20th day and the reason they give
the same as far as ending the EA is
concerned major of Scholars agree that
the EA should should end after Sunset of
the last night of
Ramadan if Ramadan is of 29 days then
after the sunset of the 29th day that is
after the first of sha start it should
end if it 30 days then after the 30th
fast is over after Sunset Thea can end
but all the scholars agree unanimously
also that it is
must as some of the sahabas they did
continue
even in the night till e
prayer So based on this some of the
scholars say it is must it's encouraged
that it should stay even of the night
before Eid that is the first day of
shaal and continue offer Salah and offer
the E Salah and then go back to your
family if you have to offer e Salah in
somewhere else in some other place in
thear you can have a bath go there and
then go and meet your family this is
preferable but otherwise all the
scholars agree that Thea can end after
Sunset after the month of Ramadan end
whether it's 29th or 30th
day once again doctor uh for the answer